Welcome, everybody to another Zoom call.
Just to allow you to everybody to use the member site to check for any announcements and
another reminder that as a whole comprehensive member, you guys get a discount for the visits.
So you'll have to call in to schedule and talk to regular area to whoever it's called to
receive that discount.
The self-schedule apparatus is set up for non-full members and then the fee for that is higher
for their visits.
So because you're a comprehensive member, you get the discount in order to get that you
want to call in.
Okay, let's get to our questions, you know, a bunch of them in, but also a reminder you
can chat in your question like everybody has been doing, but you're more comfortable
to speak, which should, instead of chatting, you mute yourself.
I haven't set up so that, you know, you can set it through Zoom that when everybody enters
they're muted.
And you'll have to unmute yourself.
I would ask that you don't unmute yourself till I get through all these questions.
First, the people that had sent them in.
And then you can unmute yourself.
So I'm going to keep you muted before that time.
Otherwise, we end up getting feedback and it gets kind of static.
You can hear you.
You take a sec.
And we don't, that interferes with this question.
So, so feel free to chat in or unmute yourself at the end, and, and, and ask the questions.
We're moving.
First question, I have been taking the black, sad capsules, that's the black, sad blood
root capsules, and the immune, that is, this person's talking about the, the immune
product that you suggested after a few weeks my number still went out significantly.
So this person's tuber markers are climbing, so 299 from 244 last month, normally is less
than 25.
Should I keep taking these?
Um, I answered the yes, of course, you know, you're not going to see, okay, there's nothing
short of thoughts and that is going to make a change in a growing cancer within a couple
weeks.
So we have to be realists when we're dealing with cancer, we're dealing with any disease,
we're dealing with dysbiosis when we're dealing with, you know, any disease process, not
just a symptom like a headache and we're going to take an aspirin, it's going to go away.
This is a disease process that has been going on for many times, most the time, quite
some time.
So when you're trying to make a change, let's say you start the right, or you start a new
supplement, or you start a new medication, or you start chemotherapy to think that you're
going to have drastic changes immediately, while it does happen, and it has happened, you
know, with chemotherapy, with the right, with supplements, we can't say that that's
abnormal.
So, um, you know, we've got to give things time to work and time to, to do their work on
your body and get your body working.
So I would say, yes, keep taking these.
Next question, what do you suggest for small lesions or tumors in the lungs?
So tumors, or lesions in the lungs, so understand the terminal, when a radiologist looks at a
CT scan, or an MRI, or an X-ray, they call an abnormality, they'll call a lesion.
So a lesion is just a terminology used to, there's an abnormality we don't know what it is
yet.
Um, the, the terminology of difference between a tumor and a cancer is semantics really,
because in the old days, you could say a cancer was a very awful call, the tumor, so I have
a breast tumor, that's typically, they were the most breast cancer.
Now the terminology has morphed a little bit, and tumor is more used, um, don't
not always, but it's more common to use with a benign lesion, um, and you'd say a tumor.
The correct terminology is when you don't know what something is, it's called a lesion, and
the correct terminology when you biopsy it, and it is not malignant, it is not cancerous,
it would be called a benign tumor, so you wouldn't just call it a tumor, you call it a benign
tumor, but while things haven't been biopsy, prior to them being biopsies, those are viewed
on imaging of some sort, whether it be an ultrasound, MRI, CT scan, um, a PET scan or something
else, then they would be called a lesion.
So, um, the question, what do you do suggests for a small lesion or tumor in the lungs?
Well partly it depends on what it is.
So if it has been ruled out via a biopsy so that it is no to be benign, then the answer
to that could be very different versus its thought to be, and we didn't do a biopsy on it
yet, but it's thought to be a metastatic lesion that's the testercise from the breast cancer,
let's say.
Test cancer and now I'm showing lesions in the lung, well to good chance that it's some,
if those lesions weren't there prior on any scans, it's a good chance that their metastatic,
it's metastatic cancer from the breast, and what would you do in that case?
You would continue to treat the cancer, so the things that you're doing for your breast
cancer would be the same things that you're doing for that cancer in the lungs because, you
know, again, when something metastasizes from its primary site, it's still that same
cancer.
If I have breast cancer, metastasized the lung, it's still breast cancer, it's not lung cancer.
So number one, you would treat it as the cancer, if you know it's the cancer, number two, you
treat it as the cancer, if you have a pretty good speaking suspicion that it's the cancer,
and you don't want to biopsy it to bite down, so you'd still treat it as the cancer.
What are some other things that a person could do knowing that they have metastasis to the lung?
You could, you could do nebulized therapy because you could get cancer, you could get
at the tumor more directly, so using nebulized hydrogen peroxide, we have that protocol that Dr.
Mercola's nebulized hydrogen peroxide protocol on the fake page, home page of the member site,
so I'd tell you to go back to that and do it nebulized hydrogen peroxide therapy.
That would be a smart thing to do. Then, you know, do it nebulized colloidal silver would be
another possible thing to do, whatever you have the cancer at a spot where you could possibly get
at it, you try to take advantage of those kind of things. So the other way to answer this question
is that if a person didn't have cancer, or they know that cancer has been ruled out, but they just
have lesions and tumors and lungs, again, you'd still be looking at one of the cause of those,
try to get rid of those. Causes and lesions in the lung can be infections, causes and lesions in
the lungs can be fun guy, ask for jealous type things like that, and try to deal with those specific
causes. Next question. In the article anemia, what should I do? It is it said that one should not
take iron supplements. So this person is talking about my blog, I think, so in my blog post, I wrote
the article anemia, what should I do? Should not take iron supplements if your ferritid levels are
elevated. My last blood test showed that I had very high ferritid. Should I discontinue taking the
irides? Did you send me your last blood test? Was your ferritid levels elevated?
Beyond functional range? The ranges that I put in that article, or when they beyond
on lab range. So if your ferritid levels were not beyond lab range, that I would say, no,
still keep taking the iron supplements. If they were way elevated beyond lab range, then we'd have
to think about that. The reason why I say don't take iron, if your ferritid levels are elevated is
because highly elevated ferritid levels are also a sign of inflammation and we don't want to
add to that inflammation. So you look at other things as well in that progression of understanding.
But just in general, if a person has low red blood cell count and other signs of anemia,
but their ferritid levels are through the roof, then we have to consider backing off on the iron.
So I would want to look at that level. If you're still within lab range, but outside of functional
range, then I'd say we're going to continue to take the iron. If you're way beyond lab
range, I'd say your ferritid levels are a thousand that I would say we're not going to take iron.
We don't because iron can cause more inflammation. So that's how we would analyze that.
I am up three to five times a night to urinate. What could be the reason for this? Is there a test
I could take to find out the cause? So there's several reasons why a person will get up to go to the
bathroom. You could have, if you have a tumor in your abdomen that's pressing on your bladder,
you have a smaller bladder and you're getting this sensation that you have to go to the bathroom
because you have an increased pressure on your bladder sphincter. So how your bladder sphincter
works neurologically, it sends a message to your brain to wake you up if there's a lot of pressure
on it. If you have an abnormal amount of pressure, simply because the tumor is putting physical pressure
on the bladder, thereby decreasing the volume of fluid that the bladder can hold without putting
pressure on the sphincter and it's signaling to your body to get up to go to the bathroom. There's
it a whole lot you can do about that. The bladder sphincter is controlled by your parasympathetic nervous
system. So working on parasympathetic nervous system exercises could be helpful. So let's say a person
doesn't have a tumor in their abdominal cavity putting pressure on the bladder so everything I
just said is null and void. Well, other reasons why a person will have to go to the bathroom. Their
male, obviously, the first thing is is prosthetic hypertrophy. And so they're not getting full emptied
of the bladder, but they're getting that sensation that they have to get up to go to the bathroom three
and a four times a night. If let's take that out of the picture, male or female, that's not an issue
and what are some other reasons? If a person is stuck in sympathetic tone, they're going to have an
increase lead to your day and day. So your sympathetic nervous system, that's why, okay, if you're
scared and you're frightened, you lose control of your bladder, you could pee yourself a little bit,
right? Because that's in a sympathetic overtone, you lose parasympathetic neurological
condition of the tone of the sphincter and you can lose, you know, you can
urinate a little bit. So you doing parasympathetic exercises would be helpful. So go back to the
blog, search parasympathetic, I have a video on it, I am downloading how to stimulate your vagal
nerve, that's your parasympathetic, how to calm your sympathetic, that's your messing cephalon,
so messing cephalon, calming exercises, that's sympathetic calming exercises and parasympathetic
or vagal stimulating exercises. Those are some things I would think about. Other possibilities are,
a person has a UTI, something like that, that's not an uncommon thing to have that you have to deal
with as far as testing for that, testing for a UTI would be even just do it in your dipstick,
if that shows up any type of bacteria, that's a possibility, if it's a viral it won't show up
to that. So as far as is there a test to find out the cause, you'd kind of walk through those
pieces first. If you do a standard blood test, a CBC and you showed an elevated white blood cell
count, then you consider an infection as well as that, it's not would be necessarily specific to the
bladder or anything like that, but you could look at your symptoms and figure that out,
and then again with the elevated white blood cell count on CBC, you look at it for an elevated
neutrophil count versus an elevated lymphocytic count, and that's how you'd help determine whether
it's a viral infection or a bacterial infection as far as next question. How to decrease a tumor
or a growth? Bergamit or Chaga are mentioned in an article about tumors. Do I test out for either
or are there other ways to decrease the size? So in general, when you're treating,
when we're you know, testing for what is going to, so what I do, your cheek swan testing,
understand, I'm locking into cancer and we're going from there. So, but not testing really for other
things, people will often ask, did you test with food sensitivities? No, we're only testing for the
cancer issues. In cheek swan testing, it's not the best way to test food sensitivities. Did you
test for other things for X, Y and Z issue that I have? No, that's not what I'm doing. I'm testing
for the cancer and what's going to be best for the cancer. So, if we're talking about how the best
way to decrease a tumor, you're talking about it's a cancerous related tumor, then we are doing
everything that we can do as far as from a nutritional standpoint. I wouldn't necessarily add
Bergamit or Chaga or anything else that you might read about. Unless you really, you know, you read
read about something and you're afraid about it, you really, really, really feel strongly that God
is telling you to do something, then by all means, overwrite anything I'm telling you to do
and make that decision, but we are doing the things that we are that we want to do to decrease
the size. How do you feel about mistletoe and D17? So, B17 is, my name is B17 is also my name is
Leandro. So, I'm a big fan of both mistletoe and B17. You know, so those are two different
things that can be used for cancer. So, B17 is an oxidized agent. That's how it works.
So, it could be coupled with just about any other therapy. Mistletoe works on a totally different
principle. It's not actually mistletoe that's killing cancer at all. Mistletoe is just a
hyperimmune stimulant in how it works. So, you're doing either mistletoe IV or mistletoe injection,
the whole purpose of it is your mistletoe is an irritant. It's an irritant to your immune system.
It's a very strong irritant to your immune system and what it does is it stimulates an immune response.
So, it stimulates this huge cytopide response, so it can stimulate a TH1 immune system response.
So, it can be great for cancer. So, I am all four of these things, they can be great therapies.
I tried some last year and I reacted with a huge lump. So, I know we're talking about mistletoe.
I mean, mistletoe injections, the whole how you know it's working is that you're creating this
inflammatory process. You should get this big red spot on your belly when you do that injection.
That's if you don't, then you don't have the right dose. You want to get it to the dose where you're
getting this great big red spot and it can be even irritant. It should feel hot. You might not feel
well. That's how it works. So, but I may try it again and try other kinds. This would be a trust
con for the ability to do this. So, I want to know how you feel about this. So, I think those are
fine options. I don't have anything against those whatsoever. Next question. I'm going to add
Ivermectin to my protocol to fight breast cancer and Lyme. What dosage would you suggest I start at
and then what dosage to aim for? Should it be taken every day or a few days a week?
So, the dosage for cancer and the dosage for Lyme could be very different.
The typical dosage for cancer, and I do have this on the member site, on the home page of the
member site. Typically, the starting dosage of Ivermectin for cancer is you have to just on your
computer calculate your weight in kilograms. So, it's based upon your weight in kilograms. So,
let's say if I weigh 200 pounds, I would have to go to just search pounds to kilogram conversion
and you type in 200 pounds equals 90 kilograms. So, that I'm always looking at my weight in
kilograms. So, I weigh 90 kilograms. Starting dose for Ivermectin for cancer is typically
1.5 milligrams per kilogram per day. So, if I weigh 90 kilograms, that I 1.5
milligrams would be 45 milligrams per day for cancer. Typically, Ivermectin is taken daily.
Now, understand the second part of your question. Should I take it every day or a few days a week?
The typical protocol for Benbenzole starts at three days a week or four days a week,
but there's people that are taking it every day of the week and the same thing with Ivermectin.
Typically, it's taken every day. However, you know, there's no set perfect protocol for
any of these things, right? So, there's people taking it all over the board. So, there's some people
doing Ivermectin. And less than that, there's some people doing it much higher. There's some people
that are doing 2 milligrams per kilogram weight. So, in that case, they'd be taking 180 if you weigh
200 pounds, you'd be taking 80 kilograms. You'd be taking 180 milligrams a day. Well,
it's a lot of Ivermectin. But if you had stage 4 cancer and you had a couple weeks to live,
hey, maybe that would be the way to jump into it. But if you're not in that category,
you may want to work up to it. So, everybody's going to respond differently to it.
And so, you just have to remind yourself of that. Can you have negative effects given that you have
live as well with Ivermectin? I don't know because there's just not an update about that yet.
Could Ivermectin kill Borrelia bacteria quickly? Again, I don't know. Ivermectin is typically not
used to kill for a person as live, and they go in, they never get a prescription for Ivermectin
for a live. So, it's not in the category of killing bacteria. So, can Ivermectin kill bacteria?
I don't know, maybe. Maybe it's going to be better aimed at killing other viral co-infections of
life. The concern that you would have if it does kill bacteria, Borrelia burgodorphy is the bacteria
for live, and it's a gram-negative bacteria. If you kill that too quickly, you will liberate
lipopolysaccharides, which can be very toxic to your brain, and you can get herxiber reactions.
So, that's the only thing that I would be careful if you have been, have a history of being prone to
herxiber reactions. Maybe not even starting at the cancer dosage for Ivermectin and starting at a
much lower dosage like maybe 12 milligrams per day and see how you tolerate that. As always,
you don't ever want to put yourself in a crisis situation because you overdose on something,
but might be an overdose to you, might not be, might be an overdose to other people. But starting
slow is always the best way to go. Next question. Would you recommend bed-dissol or bed-dissol
to go with it and at what dosage and for how long? I think this is the same, maybe the continuation of
that person's question. If one stays at a dosage of 22 milligrams on the bed-dissol, do they need
frequent liver labs done? Yes, no. So again, you should start off with a baseline of doing a
comprehensive metabolic panel so that we can see your liver, labs, your alkaline phosphates,
AST and ALT. Oh, they're all within normal limits and we start you start on let's say 220
milligrams and you do another test in a month. Oh, they're all within normal limits. It had no effect
and you want to move up. That's how you would test. You would test and move up as you can. I've had
people on bed-bed-dissol and it not affect their liver whatsoever just because they tend to detox
it just fine. And I've had some people, they can't tolerate 220 milligrams because it just
throws their liver markers off. So everybody's different. The only way you could know is to test. So
getting that liver markers done, if they stay within normal limits after you're on your dosage,
then they're most likely going to stay within the normal limits and you don't necessarily have to
do them every month. Do you coach patients with Parkinson's at your clinic? I have a close. I have a friend
who's son-in-law only 41 years old was diagnosed with it and I recommended your clinic told her I
would ask about coaching for him. Yes, at no at different levels, they certainly wouldn't be a part of
the Zoom call. This is only for cancer patients. I've had Parkinson's patients in the past. The
right can be extremely helpful for Parkinson's but the biggest thing is doing antibody testing,
neural antibody testing to find out what is what is going on with them as far as do they have antibodies
to neural tissue. They always do. And then how to find the triggers and reduce the inflammation.
So you have to do, there's a lot of labs that are involved with that. So it's a totally,
it's a little bit different level of care. And that's one of the reasons, not just Parkinson's,
but it's all autoimmune issues and the reason why I created the chronic disease in autoimmune course.
So if they're willing to work through that course and work through understanding and educating
themselves, then by all means we who we take on people with different cases.
Does your genetic testing include checking for the BRCA gene for breast cancer?
Yes, so the BRCA genes, remember, they're just families of genes. There's actually dozens and dozens
of BRCA genes. Now there are just a few really common ones that have been well researched that show
that show can't be positive for with horrible related cancers like the like ovarian cancer,
uterine cancer, and breast cancer. But understand the BRCA genes are tumor suppressor genes.
Having defects on your tumor suppressor genes isn't to cause for cancer. That doesn't cause cancer.
However, when you have defects on tumor suppressor genes, you are going to have a decreased sensitivity
to your body responding when a cell goes into rapid replication. You'll have a decreased sensitivity
in its response time to stimulate what's called the intrinsic apoptotic pathway. So apoptosis,
normal program cell death, while you can stimulate normal program cell death from the outside of
the cell, like vitamin D does that, attaches to the estrogen beta receptor and it stimulates
extrinsic, the extrinsic apoptotic pathway. That's actually how that works. And if a person has
estrogen receptor and progesterone receptor positive cancer, you have quote-unquote bad
estrogens that attach to that estrogen beta receptor blockade vitamin D's desire to attach to that,
to stimulate the extrinsic apoptotic pathway thereby to kill the cell. So again, even
having an ER positive cancer, bad estrogens are the cause of the cancer. The cancer, something
got inside the cell and caused that DNA damage that is causing the cell replication.
It isn't the fact that you have defects to tumor suppressor genes, nor isn't the fact that your
cancer is ER or PR positive that you have the cancer. It's just that those things are decreasing
your ability to kill the cancer either extrinsically from the outside of the cell or intrinsically
for the inside of the cell because the tumor suppressor genes roll, where a cell goes into rapid
replication is to stimulate this cap-sase pathway inside the cell called the intrinsic apoptotic pathway
that causes cell destruction from the inside out. Well, if I have defects to my tumor suppressor
genes, that can be hindered. That's also why I don't want you to take a bunch of excess methyl groups
because if you take a bunch of excess methyl groups, it actually can silence the tumor suppressor
genes. So I may not even have any defects on my tumor suppressor genes, but because I'm taking
excess methyl groups, I'm actually turning them off and hindering my body's ability to stimulate
that intrinsic apoptotic pathway. So, long answer to this question. Yes, we're testing for
bronca gene defects. If I did not know it, I understand. If you got your genes back, it'll be at the
end of the, so you got the, you get three reports. You get the full genetic report, which is like
380 plus pages. You get the genetic summary report, which is like 20 pages and it would be at the
bottom, the end of that genetic summary page. There's a section where it says tumor suppressor
genes. Now, some people have no defects in any other tumor suppressor genes. That means, at least
from a genetic standpoint, you have no hindrances of the intrinsic apoptotic pathways function.
From a genetic standpoint, you can have excess methyl groups. You can have other damaged
toxins in cells that can block that level of a lot, but from a genetic standpoint, that's not hindered.
So, if that's not highlighted, the bronca genes are not highlighted on you, but understand the
bronca genes are only what a, you know, a couple dozen different tumor suppressor genes systems
that we look for. So, I look at all those tumor suppressor genes systems and I'll highlight the
ones where you have a lot of defects, and then there's some interventions that may go along with it.
So, it would be at the end of that end of that genetic summary page. So, even in the full genetic
380 page, I think there's, you don't see the bronca, did you see any of the other tumor suppressor
just? The genetic workup tests for literally 90,000 genes. I mean, it would be, it would be too many
pages to even put in there. So, when I'm looking for the tumor suppressor genes, they're not even in
the normal. I have to search, I'm searching for them. So, it takes a long time to do your genetic workup
because I have to search for each one of them. So, that's what you would look for.
I got my results written, but did not see it. I have so many cognitive issues with Lyme that I have
not been able to listen to the classes or read about it. Thank you. So, just look at the genetic summary.
I know that not everybody's real nerdy and wants to dig into all these pages, and it's like, just tell
me what to do. Big dammit. I get it. So, you don't want to look at the genetic summary. Just look at the
genetic action steps. That's the only 3 page. That's why we did this. I understand that
not everybody's like, what are you doing? I get it. But I also feel like my colleague is
to be a teacher. So, I always try to teach you guys. So, we try to summarize as much as possible. So,
the gene course and all those videos are just for people who really want to nerd out. And that's why
we have very few views on that. Okay, next question. Is it better to take Fitment as a four days
in a row or to skip a day for the week? Good question. Now, the truth is the original
from Joe Chippen's protocol was three days off, and it was three days in a row. But since that,
it's been literally all over the board. There are people that just do it every other day period.
They just do it every other day. I tend to think to do it four days in a row or better.
Now, I can be totally wrong when somebody else could get on and say, I have done it. No, I think it's
what my cancer and remission it. I've done it every other day. You know, then everybody's
literally across the board with this. There's some people that do it every single day. There's
some people that just do it one day a week. It's just literally all over the board. I tend to think,
I'm coaching you. I'd say do it four days at a row. I have struggled with panic attacks
assumingly from the line for ages. What I started treating with the right and supplements
who suggested the panic mostly subsided except for late afternoons and evenings. Can you think of
anything that would cause this and do you have any suggestions for what I could do to eliminate
these they are tormenting? Typically, panic attacks are from inflammation in the brain.
The inflammation can be from a pathogen. It could be from a living organism, like lime or co-infections.
That's possibility. If they've been going on for ages, then I would say probably not a living
organism. Any longer, I would say it would be damaged at a living organism, maybe initially did.
You have the way your brain cleans things up is through a type of glial cell called your
microglial cells. Your microglial cells are your scavenging cells. Think of them as the macrophages
in the brain and their immune response in the brain. They help get rid of toxins in the brain. They
help get rid of pathogens in the brain. They both encapsulate. They move. They are like little octopi
that move around the brain to devour bad guys. If they can damage, they can get damaged and get stuck
in this phase that causes inflammation. So damage to microglial cells can be actually source of
constant inflammation. That is the possibility. Microglial damage happens because of trauma,
because of toxin exposure to the brain, because of biotoxin exposure to the brain in the brain,
things that damage your blood brain barrier get across the blood brain barrier. That's why I'm totally
against vaccines because vaccines and nanoparticle elements that readily cross the blood brain barrier
and damage the brain, and you end up with what's called primed microglial cells. I have a video on
that microglial priming, neurological inflammation, microglial priming. You can look that up as well.
And worse than that, the next worst step is that after a period of time and that's going on,
then you end up with antibodies to neural tissue so that you actually have circulating antibodies
in your bloodstream to neural tissues. So every time you stimulate your immune response, you'll
thereby kill neural tissue. You'll kill that tissue so you can end up with demilinating
diseases and all sorts of different things. And then we give those different names like MS and all
that kind of stuff. But in truth, it's simply antibodies, not simply very dangerous antibodies to neural
tissue. That's what you see in these cases. Now, what else can be stimulant of these things?
So you have to look for what are called triggers. Common trigger in any panic attacks, OCD issues,
anxiety issues, is glutamate increases. So a person can, so you have neurotransmitters in the
brain. Some are some are calming neurotransmitters like GABA and some are excitatory neurotransmitters
like glutamate. So glutamate is an excitatory neurotransmitter. You need glutamate and you need GABA.
It's all about balance. But if I have excess glutamate, I'm going to have an increase in anxiety.
So what could cause an excess glutamate? Well, you could actually be making too much glutamate
to reconverting glutamate, which is the amino acid found in food, to glutamate and thereby you're
creating too much glutamate, or you're just not getting rid of glutamate very well because of
damage microglue or the brain. Certainly, you don't want to be consuming glutamate. So make sure
you're not eating a diet that has processed foods that have any types of hidden glutamates. They
can amount of sodium glutamate. So make sure that you're protected that way. Decreasing inflammation
would be the other thing. You want to look at anything else that is increasing inflammation,
and certainly food can do that. So all night long, you're fasting, right? You wake up in the morning,
you've been fasting all night long, fasting will decrease inflammation in the brain. So
therefore, therefore, you're going to probably be better in the morning. And then as you have to eat
breakfast, you have to eat to live, and you have to eat lunch, you're causing inflammation,
especially if you have antibodies to different foods. So running a Cyrex array 10 would be very
wise in this case. Because as the day goes on, you're consuming foods, you're causing more inflammation,
and then it's building up and you're getting more inflammation in the brain. Your issues are worse
in the afternoon and evening, maybe even causing sleep issues. But by the time the morning rolls around,
you've been fasting for 12 hours, and now that inflammation is decreasing, and you feel better in the
morning. So those are the kind of things that I would think about moving forward with this. You want
a chat about it more. Feel free to make an appointment, we can chat more about it. But looking at Cyrex
panels, antibody panels, especially the Cyrex 10 food antibody panels would probably be a good thing.
But you did my cheek swab. You indicated cause was toxicity. In the past, you've been more specific.
So do you know what kind of toxicity it's been? I've been on binders for two years,
so I'm wondering why it's popping up now. Well, I don't know why. So when I do a cheek swab test,
sometimes people go, why did that show up? Why are you putting me on this? I've never been on this before.
I've just relayed the information here to get me out of the messenger. So this is just what came up
in your testing. The other way to find out more specifically what type of toxicity would be to do
some toxicity panels. Now you started with us a long time ago, the person who asked this question.
Currently, people that start with us, we highly recommend that we get toxicity panel. So doing the
toxic detect test, it's a urine test, doing the microtoxid test would be a good thing to do. If you haven't
done those, I don't know if you've done those, I know you're going to other practitioners as well.
So those would be some things to help uncover different toxins.
I've been doing foot baths for about a year in light of this toxicity. Should I go back to doing them?
You can. I'm not a huge fan of the eye on pro wave and pulling out toxins. I would say if you have
a sauna or it's coming into summer, if you can sweat, that would be better. That's just my opinion.
Next question. I went to every other day for coffee. Enemies tried to make sure my body could have
all movements on its own. Should I go back to doing every day? I know that's a hard choice. Some people
don't like to feel like they're dependent upon doing coffee enemies or having all movements, but
I just don't know. To me, it's like why is that a bad thing? The only reason why that would
be a bad thing if I was in something where I had to travel a lot. It's hard to do that. I can
understand that, but if that's not you, you're at home. It certainly is health-benefit-wise,
aerosipinant stimulation, detoxification stimulation, to do them on a daily basis.
Were there other therapies that stood out that I should try? I'm just walking fast,
rectercise, and it's starting to get hot again in Florida, so I try to go outside the sweat.
So I think sweating is going to be your friend. I think that's the best. One of the best ways to
take pressure off of your liver and your kidney is to help remove toxins through sweating.
When you did my cheek swab this week, looks like you suggested supplements just for cancer,
that you labeled balancers. What does this mean? Well, years ago we changed our terminology just
for our protection. When state boards come after you, and to throw you in prison,
you have to be a little bit more cautious of what you're doing and what you're saying. So we can't
say cancer killers anymore. We say balancers, so that's kind of how we use that terminal.
Since you did the recheck due to my tumor markers increasing, and you came back with the
tippance protocol plus a parasite cleanse, could it be a parasitic infection that had caused by
tumor markers to rise? I don't know. I don't, I don't, and maybe I just haven't looked, but I haven't
seen any data that says a parasitic infection will cause tumor markers to rise. I don't think so.
I gave you a list of my supplements, which was a lot of items for reference. Did you not
comment on them because I shouldn't take them anymore? Or is it up to me since you concentrated on
the most important, which included quite a few new things? I wondered if I keep
aching stuff like dim and melatonin and thyroid glandular and turkey tail or your mushroom mix.
So I've just been confused on what to do with my prior program because maybe I should have
someone local test me once I have all the new things gathered to see what I should still take
from the old program. The only thing that I would say that you should take from the old program would
be this thyroid glandular because that is tied to the cancer. That's your thyroid gland. That's not
going to test for cancer. The other things I would just put in the refrigerator and say,
you wanted a complete reset. That's what you asked for. So that's what I did. So I did it. You know,
I've just locked into cancer and tested what is going to be the most important for you? The other
ones didn't come up. The thyroid glandular won't come up for cancer anyway. So that's a completely
separate thing. You're doing that for thyroid. I would keep doing that. But I tested for it and gave
you the data for cancer. So okay, to the chat. After stopping Joe Tippen's protocol by BUN and
creatinine are finally back in range. Yay! But my chloride is slightly high. Okay, so what would cause
chloride to go up? So chloride is going to go up with metabolic acidosis or adrenal stress. So
those are the two things that are going to cause chloride to go on. Your globulin is slightly low.
Well, globulin is not going to really tie to chloride. So what are the ways you could develop? Okay,
what is it? Metabolic acidosis or adrenal stress? Well, you have to look at other factors too,
remember? We'll just look at the clues. Typically, you're going to have an increased chloride levels.
With adrenal stress, you're going to have increased chloride levels associated with adrenal
hyperfunction. Meaning like you're at a lot of stress right now, your adrenals are really ticking out.
So that adrenal exhaustion. So there's a difference between adrenal stress and adrenal exhaustion.
You also have to consider it's a adrenal stress. If your chloride levels are increased along with
your, many times your sodium will be increased and your evidence slightly decrease in potassium,
because you're birdied through potassium with your adrenals under the stress.
If it's metabolic acidosis, you could have increased chloride with a decreased CO2.
Along with an increased chloride and an increased, what's called an aniam gap.
That's the difference. That's the separation between your anions. You're positively,
negatively charged minerals. So those are the kinds of things that you kind of balance that out.
You're estimated, well, in a very low filtration rate, regularly low, around 72.
Well, and if you look at the rest of your blood work as well, because remember, all these things
just compare to one another. Next question. Is glutathione okay to take if one has hormone
positive breast cancer? One of the well-known line doctors recommends glutathione, high dose,
and alkycels are gold, or herxide really. What are your thoughts on this?
Well, if you didn't have cancer, glutathione is a great thing to take for anybody with autoimmune
disease. So they don't have a cancer diagnosis, but I have autoimmune disease, or stage three
line. It's glutathione, a good thing to take. Absolutely. So I would totally agree with that doctor,
with cancer throws a whole other thing in it. So you're going to take glutathione with cancer.
You're at risk of keeping cancer cells alive. So personally, I would not do that with cancer.
Though if you if you were in full remission, and your cancer wasn't active, then by all means you
can throw out that advice. But if your cancer is active, and you're dealing with trying to kill cancer,
I would not use glutathione. I said to you the results. Next question. I said to you the results
of the RGCC, I would like to know your opinion on baking soda. As every time I had a little into my
water, I get nauseous and a lump in my throat and a syphagus and blurred vision immediately,
does this mean I should do it? Well, maybe that's a good idea. Okay, but I do have some information
on baking soda on the website. I'm not a fan of using baking soda at all. You're alkalizing,
you're stomach, you're setting yourself up for H by Laura. Infections, you're definitely set
yourself up for hypocal hydria. And you are also setting yourself up for vitamin B12 deficiency,
as B12 is necessary. The only way you absorb B12 is through intrinsic factor made by the
primal cells of your stomach that is completely dependent upon the acidity of your stomach in order
for that to be released. So if you're going to take baking soda or alkaline water,
if you're alkalizing your stomach by doing that thinking you're alkalizing your cancer,
unless you have cancer in your stomach, that's not a good protocol that makes absolutely no sense.
Whether you get sick from it or not, do not do that. Next question. What is your opinion of Dr.
C.B.S. alkaline diet and taking C.B.S. and fermented whatever plums also best way to keep my
up my electrolytes? Okay, so there are alkaline diets that are out there that can be beneficial. If I have
issue, look at your blood work to see, do I have metabolic acidosis? You could equally have metabolic
alkalosis. So you want to look at your blood work to determine that.
Certainly, I don't know what's involved with this person's alkaline diet, so I'm not going to make
comment on it. I'm not a big fan of taking C.B.S. either. And I don't know anything about these
fermented plums. So the best way to keep up your electrolytes is to eat a good diet. Make sure you're
eating your vegetables where you're going to get your minerals. But let's say you're sweating a lot
and you're losing minerals or you're doing sodas or whatever. And you're have low minerals
based upon your blood work again, then you take a good quality mineral, which should be a plant
based mineral or a created the same way it's found in plants, which is double bonded to an amino acid,
which is the albion or the tracks minerals that are out there. Never take a soil based mineral
or those liquid minerals. They're just a bunch of garbage. You don't get your minerals through
eating dirt. You get your minerals through eating plants. That's the way God made it. And it's
double bonded to an amino acid. So that's how you should get your minerals. There are electrolyte
products out there that are just fine too that are made with those types of minerals. So
but just taking a good mineral is the way to get your minerals. Next question. I started using
black sap since yesterday. Is it okay not to pack it in the capsule and just take it by itself?
Also, can you please explain what does it do to the body? So this isn't the recommendation for me.
So I think you're taking black sap and when you did it in a capsule,
that's not my recommended. I didn't ask you to do that just so you know. What does black sap do
to your body? So black sap is made from blood roots. So it's the herb that can help kill cancer cells.
It can help detoxify things. It can be very good for you, but it can be very caustic too. So you've
got to be careful with it. Next question. Did I understand you to say there's even more genetic info
than we received in the 200 page report? So depending on when you received your genetic report from us,
it was different pages. When I started doing the genetic report, it was only like 35 pages.
And then we were very proud that it was a 60 page report. Well, that was over 380 pages that are
reported. Yeah, but there's a whole bunch of other genes that you know, I haven't really,
they're not, you know, that nobody's looking at unless you're a cancer doctor like me. So I'm the only
one to eat the DNA supplementations report that's looking at tumor presser genes or oncogenes. So
I have to search for those. So they're not common genes that one would look for. And then there's a
ton of other genes that there's really very little to no research on. So it doesn't pay to put
them in the report because we don't know what they mean yet. So there's as data comes out on
what these different gene families do, then that report has been expanded. And now it's expanded
at 380 pages. So and I can access to it. Well, I'll have to pull yours up and download and see how
many pages come up. When we did different people's genes throughout the years, they may have tested for
less. I don't know. So I have to look. A functional doctor is curious about genetic defects and
impacting my methylation of the two hydroxy estrogens. I can, I'll make a note to download
your report again and send it to you. Next question, which would be better to start? I'm erected
or a mistletoe. I don't, you're just asking for an opinion. If you've done mistletoe in the past
and it's caused irritation, and I think you're the person that asked that question about mistletoe
earlier, then I would say do I've erected? You know, there's typically less side effects,
sometimes zero side effects that I've erected. I would say do I've erected? It was me. I would probably
do that. It's easier to come by. Next question, when you're determining the most important supplements
for cancer, are you testing? I've erected, yes, am, or an arm with the same effect that would suggest
it would be beneficial. No one testing that. Yep. Or can you not test and suggest I've erected,
no, we can, we can test for and suggest that we just can't provide it. So you'd have to get that
somewhere else. I wonder if I should consider adding to the tip and protocol. Again, it did test
for me with my all means. If you feel like you want to, you can. Yes. The only thing with I've
erected, you kind of want to find somebody that could give you a prescription because the I've
erected that you could kind of buy out there. It's typically going to be in 12 milligram capsules,
which I guess that's not so bad. So you take four of them or something like that. So I guess that's
so bad. But it would be nice if you could get it, you know, at a compounded pharmacy to get to
the dosage you want. What blood work do you look at for check-in minerals? Well, I would just start by
looking at a comprehensive metabolic profile. So looking at a comprehensive metabolic profile would
be the beginning. I did not understand what I should be careful with with black subuse. Well,
if you're taking black sub orally, I don't know what product you're taking a product that I don't
use and have never used and don't test for. So I can't vouch for a product that I don't have
little knowledge about. So I don't want to mislead anybody and say, oh, yeah, just go ahead and take
that. That would be, that would be irresponsible. So I don't, I'm not familiar with that product. I
haven't used that product. You're taking a black sub. It seems to me you're taking a black sub
ointment and putting it in a capsule and then taking it orally. So I wouldn't, I just wouldn't do
that, you know, sometimes if it's supposed to be a topical, there's other things in it that you
don't necessarily want to swallow. So there's black sub capsules out there then, you know, they're called
black sub capsules. But they have blood rooted them. And sometimes they have other ones like the ones
that we have are called black sub blood root capsules. And they have, I think four different herbs in it.
So there's, you know, I would take something orally that's meant to be used orally. Next question,
I do already have the report that's nearly 200 pages. So I only need what you have if it's more.
Okay, thank you. I'll look for now. See what yours comes up as. I remember my genetic report
that we are, the BRCA was highlighted, but the genetic test that my oncologist ran
because I was under 50 showed BRCA as negative. We're the test looking at different genes. So remember,
the BRCA genes, there's dozens and dozens of BRCA genes. They're gene family. So we say, oh, I am
defects in my BRCA genes. That means you have defects in the BRCA gene family. Now they're only
looking like I said before, typically, they're only looking at a couple of those genes, even when they
run the test, they're only tested for a couple of those genes in that gene family. To me, that's silly.
Oh, just because these are the most researched and these ones are, you know, the most research to
me the issues and those are negative. Well, if you had tons of defects in some of the other ones,
then it's like, okay, well, this could be an issue. So again, when you have defects in a gene,
it doesn't mean the gene's not going to work. It doesn't mean that, you know, you're doomed for
life. It just means that you have a greater chance of that gene not functioning as well as if you
didn't have any defects in it. I don't know why the medical profession truncates things so often.
It makes no sense to me. Is it really, is there already charged you a bloody fortune to run a test
like that? You're charged your insurance bloody fortune. Why don't they do it? Well,
it's just like having somebody go into the ER and they do a, I've seen this so many times.
They did a, they went into the ER with all these issues. They do a CBC, but they don't do a differential.
What the heck? It costs you like another two dollars to do it. I just don't understand it.
They go to the, they pick the cheapest thing. I don't get it. And then you get less information.
Next question. Two feathers, black Sabbath, a jar. I just don't use that product so I really don't,
I can't, I don't want to comment on that product. So I don't want to give you information that
could be wrong. It's been a while. When is the best time to swab my mouth and send it in? Well,
the best time like a time of day, there isn't one. We're just trying to get your genes
out there to test for that. The best time as far as how often should I do a cheek swab? I do have
a video on that on the member site. But generally how often you do a cheek swab is if there's a change.
I haven't done this for a long time. I want to get back on a protocol. Anytime people fall off
their protocol, they fall off the wagon. They haven't been doing anything. Maybe because they're doing
great. That's great. But if you kind of want to get back on a protocol, then you do another
cheek swab or if you're getting worse or if you're getting better and I want to come back on thing. So
just as far as time of the day or anything, your time of the month with your period or anything that
means that is meaningless anytime. Just get that saliva on there and send that in.
Okay. Well, I think we'll wrap it up with that. We'll talk to everybody next week.
Thanks very much. We're great for all of you, and we cherish your prayers for us. Bye-bye,